selon vous quels sont les plus grands
défis dans un musée comme celui ci nous
sommes à musée d'art moderne et
contemporain r il faut donc présenter
des oeuvres qu'ils soient la pointe de
ce qui se fait aujourd'hui
mais la concurrence sur le marché est
féroce par exemple si je place un objet
dans un musée imaginez qu'on prenne
notre sac à main et qu'on le place ici
devient-il dollar 1
[Musique]
ok cet automne nous présentons l'artiste
des sociologues argentine lola à brias
et son exposition qui s'intitule the
square un musée ne doivent pas craindre
tout dépassé les bornes
il ne faut pas céder à la peur
tu m'as traiter ce problème tu vas
connaître le chaos
il est l'heure de manger on vous a
préparé un fantastique buffet vous à
bord a coulé dernier par cl aux cèpes
avec des brides asperges s'il vous plaît
attendez un peu s'il vous perdra des
fêtes arrive souvent de rentrer avec des
femmes que tu connais pas très bien pour
coucher avec elle et être en elle
tu connais leur prénom alors comme je
m'appelle
[Musique]
le square est un sanctuaire où règnent
confiance et altruisme bien là en son
sein nous avons tous les mêmes droits et
les mêmes devoirs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]